[Music]
Robert Spencer here for jihad watch a
program of the David Horowitz Freedom
Center and for the Center for Security
Policy Alton Alexander Nolan aka Jackie
me Israel was recently found guilty of
murder for beheading a co-worker Colleen
Hufford at Vaughan foods in Moore
Oklahoma in September 2014
his trial has revealed a new the
incoherence and inconsistency of our
official response to the jihad threat
Nolan insisted he was merely following
the Koran and statements he made days
after the attack that have just been
revealed during his trial Nolan could
not have been clearer about his mindset
worldview and motivations when he was
read his rights he responded I'm a
Muslim when asked why he beheaded
Colleen Hufford he answered I just feel
like I did what I needed to do what
Allah says in the Quran to do oppressors
don't need to be here Nolan has a case
the Quran says when you meet the
unbelievers strike the necks that's
chapter 47 verse 4
Nolan thought Colleen Hufford was not
just an unbeliever but something even
worse she was he explained a slave to
the devil Nolan himself on the other
hand was a slave to Allah he told police
you know the Muslim is somebody who
submits their will to Allah whatever he
wants done that's what we do and you
know he wants us to get the oppressors
out of this place when asked if he
regretted murdering Colleen Hufford
Nollan nolan answered this wasn't
nothing but a trial for me I passed it
because like I said I felt oppressed I
knew for sure that if I was to die right
then I was going to heaven he added I
feel you know you know what I'm saying
if I was to die in five or ten minutes
I'm going to heaven that's all that
matters to me here again Nolan has a
case the Quran promises paradise to
those who kill and are killed for Allah
that's chapter 9 verse 111 Nolan is of
course still alive but like the Fort
Hood jihad mass murderer Nidal Malik
Hasan
he likely believes that if he were to be
executed it would complete the
requirements of that Quranic passage and
ensure his ticket to paradise this was
confirmed by the fact that he demanded
to be executed and said he would not
accept life imprisonment
when asked if anyone had told him to
behead unbelievers he was quite clear
about where he got the idea no he said I
read the Quran like I say the Quran is
easy to understand
no one guides me but Allah Noland also
confirms that he screamed Allahu Akbar
as he beheaded Hufford both prosecuting
and defense attorneys however seemed to
discount knowlins statements The
Oklahoman reported that his
court-appointed defense attorneys are
asking the jury to find him not guilty
by reason of insanity Cleveland County
District Attorney Gregg Mashburn
meanwhile went even farther saying that
Nolen quote didn't know the difference
between right and wrong
and didn't know the consequences of his
actions now that's nonsense Nolan knows
very well the difference between right
and wrong as the Quran explains it the
Quran says when you meet the unbelievers
strike the necks and as far as nolan is
concerned that's what's right and he
knows that as a consequence of his
actions he will go to paradise as allah
has promised mashburn was saying
essentially that standard islamic belief
was tantamount to insanity did he have
any idea of how Islamophobic he was
being we have seen this before
in montreal last march a police
complaint was filed against the dar al
kharkom mosque in montreal for hosting
an imam Sheikh Mohammed bin Musa Hal
Nasser who preached o Muslim a servant
of Allah o Muslim o servant of Allah
there is a Jew hiding behind me come and
kill him but this is a quotation that is
attributed to Muhammad the Prophet of
Islam where the Canadian police really
going to stop Imams from quoting
Muhammad our Oklahoma authorities really
going to ascribe obedience to Quranic
commands to insanity at some point
Western officials are going to have to
face the contents of Islamic
and recognize that bringing large
numbers of Muslims into the West is only
going to increase the number of
beheadings and exhortations to kill Jews
as both those things are taught in
Islamic texts right now it's
Islamophobic to point this out but this
enforced fantasy cannot forever obscure
unwelcome facts before too long the
contents of Islamic teachings will be
abundantly clear to everyone
I'm Robert Spencer
[Music]